thus spake there are through stir was
made famous and popular by 2001 and that
is a music played at this magic moment
when some primate suddenly gets an idea
presumably one of our ancestors so how
do we explain all that we've got all the
ingredients on the table and today I
want to talk about various ways of
putting those ingredients together so
we've talked about representations we've
talked about methods and today we're
going to talk about architectures and by
the end of the class you'll know how to
put one of those things together
actually no one knows how to put one of
those things together but what you will
know is about some alternatives for
putting those things together so as to
make something that's some arguably
intelligent in the same way we are so
that's our agenda for the day
well we'll also talk a little bit more
about stories the I think it was in 2007
when the Estonians moved the war
memorial from the center of Tallinn
off to a Russian War Cemetery
prior to that time the Estonians had
been building up their national computer
networks because they thought that the
computation was the way of the future
and networks and all that shortly after
the movement of that War Memorial
someone brought the Estonian national
network down cyberattack it was widely
believed to be the Russians there's a
large Russian ethnic population in
Estonia to start with and the movement
of that Worman well irritated the
Russians and so everybody everybody
thinks that they did it but you know
what no computer can understand the
story I just told they can rebel through
all the world wide web finding
information that's relevant to that but
no computer can understand the story I
just told except one you'll see them
tration that later on today so if we by
the way if you're interested in
understanding the nature of you
intelligence this is of course the most
intelligent most most important lecture
of the semester and I should tell you a
little bit about what we're going to do
on Wednesday because for some reason the
day before Thanksgiving tends to be a
lecture that's lightly populated except
in this class because I'm going to talk
about business of the artificial
intelligence business and what can be
learned from it about how to avoid going
broke when you start your company so for
many of you that will be the most
important lecture of the semester
yeah good so it all started back in the
dawn age of artificial intelligence and
really it all started that Carnegie
Mellon sad to say because of people at
Carnegie Mellon notably Newell and Simon
were the first to think about a sort of
a general purpose way of putting things
together so as to build a structure or
architecture for in which particular
intelligent systems could be built so
their idea was called the general
problem solver a long name for a simple
idea and a simple idea is that you start
your life out in a current state call it
C and you want to get to some goal state
call it s and the way you do that is you
measure somehow the symbolic difference
between where you are and where you want
to be so that's the difference we'll
call that difference D and when you
observe that difference that's enough
they say in this general approach to
problem solving for you to select some
operation that will move you from your
current state to some new state an
intermediate state call that I so I or
that operator o is determined
by the difference d and then of course
the next thing to do is to measure the
difference between that intermediate
state and the state you want to be in
and choose some operator it's relevant
to reducing that state so we'll call
that d2 and we'll call this o 2 and D 2
is what leads you to O 2 and so it goes
so that's the idea and that's often
called means-ends analysis right because
the end that you want to achieve is
being in that final state s and the
means is a that operator o so you have
some notion where you want to be and the
difference between where you are and
where you want to be and pick an
operator so as to reduce that difference
so this is all very abstract let's
exercise it in a in solving a problem
that you all be faced with here in a day
or two and that is for many of you most
of you I hope the problem of going home
so here you are you're at MIT and where
you want to be is over here at home so
you measure the difference between MIT
and home and for many of you it's
further you can go by car and not so far
that you can't go at all so what you do
is you say well the right operator is
taking an airplane so here you are
there's the operator take an airplane
and this is the difference D and the
difference D being sufficiently large
you take the airplane trouble is if you
happen to be sitting here in 10 to 50
there's no way you can take an airplane
because they don't fit in here so you've
got another problem and that is to get
to the airplane
so the distance between here R Logan is
such that the right way to do that is to
take the MBTA and that's determined
because you working on this difference
reduction right here the difference from
being an MIT and being at the airport
that difference dictates that you take
the MBTA so you see your recursing well
you know there are no MBTA cars in here
either so there's still a difference
like so and that difference dictates
that you walk so you've got D 1 D 2 and
D 3 and by the time you've exercised the
operator is relevant to those three
differences you're at Logan and you take
the airplane you get over to your
hometown and you're faced with a smaller
difference of getting from that Airport
to where you actually want to go so
that's the general problem solver ideal
it's was such an exciting idea at the
time it was it was such an exciting idea
at the time because people would say to
themselves ah this is a general purpose
problem solver so we can set it on to
the problem of making itself smarter and
so there was a kind of imagined chain
reaction that would take place and that
the developers of this architecture
warned the public that within 10 years
that isn't saved by about 1970 computers
would be generally as smartest people
and a lot of people made fun of them for
that prediction but it was actually
scientists attempting to be responsible
because they thought something quite a
quite serious dislocation was coming
along and that people should know that
it was coming and so they felt it was
their responsibility in that age of
scientific responsibility to warn the
public it didn't turn out that way
because well the problem of collecting
the differences in finding the operators
that's outside the scope of the
architecture so this is the problem that
has to be solved by a human before this
architecture can be used you have to
have identified the differences that you
might encounter and the operators then
you might use and build this table which
relates the two together so maybe that
one that one some off diagonal elements
and so on but building that table turned
out to be hard
so not surprisingly the idea evolved and
eventually the folks at Carnegie who
developed the general problem solver
most notably Newell and his students
developed a newer fresher more elaborate
architecture called soar and here's how
it works
first of all what it's or mean it
doesn't mean anything
it used to mean state operator operate
for and result but for some reason the
proponents of the soar architecture have
decided they don't like the acronym and
have asserted that soar is merely a
label that shouldn't be thought of as an
acronym in any event soar consists of
various parts it has a long term memory
and has a short term memory and it has
connections to the outside world maybe a
vision system and an action system but
most of the activity of the sewer
problem solving architecture takes place
in the short-term memory so you can view
the contents of the long-term memory as
shuttling in and out of short-term
memory so you can see right away that
this mechanism this architecture is
heavily influenced by certain cognitive
psychology experiments having to do with
how much you can hold in your short-term
memory nonsense syllables and all that
sort of thing was popular back in those
days so this was a architecture devised
primarily by psychologists and it had as
amongst its features a short-term memory
and a long-term memory so that's part
one of this architecture what was it
what's in the long-term memory
well assertions and rules
aka productions a production being the
Carnegie vernacular for rule it's just
rule based stuff like you saw in almost
the first day of class so the whole
thing is a gigantic rule-based system
with assertions and rules that shuttle
back and forth from long-term memory
into short-term memory we're processing
takes place the third thing that comes
to mind when you think of the Soraa
architectures they had a lab repression
system you would call it when we talked
about rule-based systems there was
always a question of what do you do when
more than one rule would work you have
to have some way of breaking those ties
the Soraa architecture has elaborate sub
system for doing that but I said that
these are the first three things you
think about it maybe that's not right
because the next thing you think about
is perhaps a better way of identifying
to identify with the Soraa architecture
and that's the idea of problem spaces
and that's the idea that if you're going
to solve a problem you have to develop a
space and do a search through that space
just like we did when we talked about
how we can get from here to home if
there's a space of places that's our
problem space we can do a search through
that space to find a way to get from one
place to another that's the sort of
thing that sort is focused on finally
the fifth element you tend to think
about when you think about soar is the
idea of universal sub going
and that's the idea that whenever you
can't think of what to do next that
becomes your next problem that deserves
its own problem space and its own set of
differences and operators and rules and
assertions so you start off on a high
level then you have to solve problems at
a lower level just like you did up there
with the general problem solver so if
you have these two architectures you can
begin to say well what are they centered
on and this architecture is this general
problem solver centered on the idea that
everything is about problem solving is
the problem solving hypothesis no one
gave it that name but that's what it was
and this architecture did get its name
and it was called always it was said
always by Newell to be based on what he
called the symbol system hypothesis
the hypothesis that what we are as
humans is symbol manipulators and we can
uncover how that all works by giving
people crypt arithmetic problems and
having them talk out loud by thinking
about what happens when you try to
remember nonsense syllables by all that
sort of stuff that was in Voges in terms
of psychology experiments in the day
when this architecture was first
articulated but when you look at
architectures you can sort of see where
they come from and what their
antecedents are has a short-term memory
and a long-term memory because Newell
and his associates were cognitive
scientists it has assertions and rules
and preferences because Newell and his
associates were also AI people and has
problem spaces and Universal sub going
because those are ideas that have been
worked out in a more primitive form all
already already in the general problem
solver architecture so that's a glimpse
of what sort of like its early days it's
been very highly developed by a lot of
smart people so although it's symbol
centered they've attached to it things
having to do with emotion and perception
but generally with the view that the
first thing to do when faced with a
perception is to get it out of there and
give it into a symbolic form that's sort
of the bias that you let the
architecture that the architecture comes
with so those are two architectures that
are heavily biased toward thinking that
the important part of what we do is
problem solving but the most important
perhaps at least from an MIT perspective
of these problem-solving oriented ways
of thinking about the world is Marvin
Minsky's architecture which he
articulates in his book the emotion
machine
and marvin is not just concerned with
problem-solving but also how
problem-solving might come in layers so
let me show you an example of the sort
of problem that motivates some of the
Marvin's thinking so you can read that
it's a short little vignette we have no
trouble understanding it right now it's
not difficult for us humans I'll play
tough for a computer in part because the
thinking you need to the ability to
understand that story requires you to
think on many levels at the same time
first of all there's a sort of at the
bottom there's instinctive reaction you
see where there's instinctive reaction
yeah that's the part where she hears a
sound and turns her head that's instinct
by this practically built-in but then
what she sees is a car so that's
something that you know we don't have
wired in it would be unlikely that we've
evolved in the last 100 years to have an
instinctive appreciation of cars
barreling down the road so the next
level in Marvins architecture is learned
reaction
so that's the part about thinking about
the car now spread throughout there well
let's see where's a particularly good
example
she decides to sprint across the road so
that's where she's solving a problem so
that's the deliberative thinking level
but doesn't stop there because later on
she reflects on her impulsive decision
so she thinks not only about stuff
that's happening out there in the world
but she also thinks about what stuff
that's going on in here so that's a
level where we can push which we can
call reflective thinking well you know
it doesn't stop there because she also
considers in another part of the story
something about being uneasy about
arriving late so she's not only just
thinking about events that are going on
in her mind right now but the events
that are going on right now relative to
plans she's made and so Marvin calls
that the self reflecting layer
but that isn't the whole thing either
because the toward the end of the story
she starts to worry about what her
friends would think of her so there's a
kind of reflective thinking in the
content in a more social context so he
calls that self-conscious thinking so
whereas the funny folks think the so
architecture focuses mostly on problem
solving in skis emotion machine book
considers not just thinking by thinking
on many layers and the blocker to doing
any of that can be said to be the
development of common sense which
computers alas have never had much of so
this is to be said to be based on the
common sense hypothesis and the common
sense hypothesis holds and in order to
do all of that stuff you have to have
common sense like people and if you have
to have common sense like people you
have to think about well how much of it
is how much of that is there and how can
we go get it
and so this spawned a lot of activity in
the Media Lab amongst people influenced
by Marvin having to do with gathering
common sense the open mind project the
works of hand rule even when others
having to do with the gathering of
common sense from the world wide web as
a way of populating systems that would
lay the foundation for doing this kind
of layered thinking so that is a brief
survey of some mechanisms some older
than others but all but GPS GPS - let's
face it it's hard to think of solving
any problem without means-ends analysis
being involved so GPS isn't wrong it's
just not all you need to think it's not
the only tool you need to think about
what to
so these are early and late and still
current but it's not the only thing
there is because there have been
reactions against this problem-solving
way of thinking about the development of
intelligence and the most prominent of
those counter currents of those
alternative ideas belongs to Rodricks
and his subsumption architecture so long
about the early long about the years
surrounding 1990 Brooks became upset sub
sumption because robots couldn't do much
they would turn them on at night and
then the next morning that come into
laboratory and they would have moved 25
feet nicely avoiding a table perhaps but
not doing very much and taking a long
time to do it so he decided that it's
because people were thinking in the
wrong way in those days people thought
that the way you build a robot is you
build a vision system and then you build
a reasoning system and then you build an
action system and it can do almost
nothing but it does something so you
improve the vision system and you
improve the reasoning system and you
improve the action system and now you've
broken it because all the stuff that you
used to be able to do doesn't work
anymore so what what's the alternative
well the alternative as articulated by
Brooks is to turn this idea on its side
so instead of having a encapsulated
vision system and encapsulated reasoning
system and capsulate action system what
you have is layers that are focused not
on the sensing and the reasoning and the
action but layers that are sensitive
they're specialized to dealing with the
world
so in Brooks's way of thinking about
things at the lowest level you might
have a system that's capable of well
before we get to that avoiding objects
and maybe the next level up is the
wandering layer
and maybe the next level up after that
is explore and maybe the next level up
after that is seek now in the old days
when people took six mm I had no trouble
getting an answer to the question of
what does this remind you of in 6mm one
well
doesn't remind you anything six double
ones that you haven't taken it but as a
if you'd as a generalization of a
programming idea what is the programming
idea there are only a few powerful ideas
in programming and this is a
generalization of one of them what is it
do you have a name
yes Andrew layers of abstraction
abstraction bound and abstraction
barriers that nails it pretty well
because each of these guys can have its
own vision action and reasoning system
and if you think of these as abstraction
boundaries then when you got this thing
working you don't screw with it anymore
you build this layer on top and it may
reach down in here from time to time but
it doesn't fundamentally change it
Brooks was inspired in part by the way
our planes are constructed all that old
stuff that we share with pigs is down in
there deep and we put the neocortex over
it so it looks layered in a way that
would make Gerry Sussman proud so this
then is the way that Brooks looks at the
world and it's characterized by a few
features just like just like soar is one
of those features is no representation
so this is a just a detail that's
probably right at the level that Brooks
was operating and very questionable when
you get above the level that Brooks is
operating but before I go on let me say
what the what the hypothesis is the
hypothesis is the creature hypothesis
it's the hypothesis that once you can
get a machine to act as smart as an
insect and the rest will be easy well
how do you get a creature to be smart as
an insect maybe you don't need
representation we focus on
representation in this course so you can
see that there's a little stress when I
don't wonder
next thing is well what do you do if you
don't have a representation let's see a
representation makes a model possible
models make it possible to predict to
understand to explain and to control so
if you don't have one what can you
possibly do well Brooks his answer is
you use the world instead of a model so
everything you do is reactive you don't
have anything your head that is a map of
this room but maybe I don't need one
because I can get a get around that
table by constantly observing it and we
don't have to fill up a memory with that
information I can just react to it
so no representation use the world
instead of a model and the mechanisms in
their purest form are just finite state
machines so with that
Brooks was able to do things that people
were never able to do before
what's the modern instantiation of this
architecture now according to Brooks in
use in five million homes the United
States yeah it's the Roomba the rhumba
robot is my Brooks's account
approximately the 13th business plan of
iRobot and it's the one that made it big
because the rhumba vacuum cleaner has
been very successful would you like to
see a movie of its predecessor ok so
this is a film made some time ago that
shows in some sense the Summa of that
architecture what I want you to imagine
very briefly is a robot that wanders
around in the halls and rooms of the old
tech square collecting the coke cans ok
y'all got an image of that in your mind
because I want you to compare the image
you now have of that robot that's
wandering around collecting the coke
cans with the actual movie
per the soda can collecting Lolo Rolla
it was built at the MIT AI lab in 1989
work was done by John Canal under the
supervision of Rodney Brooks pervert is
a robot controlled by subsumption
architecture this is a collection of
small behaviors that influence the
overall activities of the robot there
are no centralized controllers and no
world model pervert navigates by using a
number of infrared proximity sensors
around its body and basically following
walls and corridors you can also look
for the cab with a laser lights driver
right now come out of the door of an
office followed along the wall and then
it's laser light Stryker has seen a cab
on top of the desks in front of it when
this happens
robot stops and deploys it are you can
see the arms going out now the arm has a
number of sensors itself they're
fingertip sensors a break beam in the
jaws and two infrared proximity sensors
on the front of the hand it grabs cams
in a stereotyped fashion first it lowers
down to find a surface somewhere then it
bounces along the surface until it see
the can in front he uses the hand based
IRS to recenter the arm by rotating the
robot's body until the cam comes between
the jaws of the gripper at which point
the break beam senses the cat after
acquiring an Herbert will tuck the arm
back into its normal traveling
configuration and attempt to go home
since it has no central our presentation
it doesn't have any map of where it came
from
instead it has an algorithm which uses a
magnetic compass to determine every time
it comes through a door will it be able
to find the door basically has a policy
of always going north every time it
exits the door so now that camp being
tucked away as the robot turns you'll
see a red stripe from the laser
rangefinder and now excusing the bonny
IR to navigate back find the door and go
through the door with this prize
and there if your pay attention you saw
a little glimpse of John Canal who was
the student who developed that system so
that was a tour de force that was a
magic moment that when you open a
champagne it's not what you expected of
course because when I say imagine a
robot wandering around at x-square
picking up the coke cans that leaves it
open a huge envelope of possible
hallucinations and usually our who's
nation's about these things are we
imagine things to be more more fluid
more natural and more impressive than
they actually are but that was
impressive because no robber nobody came
close to doing anything like that before
mortals more to be said about that
during the business lecture on on on
Wednesday so that's the subsea knock
texture by the way
maybe at this point we can say something
about how the other architectures relate
to what Minsky was talking about
what's this deliberative thinking layer
correspond to well that's what that's
what soar is about and maybe GPS so
what's what's absurd about it's about
stuff down here you know it's about
instinctive reaction and learned
reaction
let's shoot
what about Minsky's other layers if
we're going to be building systems that
are smart as those things I'm gonna have
to worry a little bit about that sort of
thing too so that brings us to the to
the Genesis architecture and now let me
give you the standard caution this
should be early in the presentation of
any academic I will sometimes say I and
what I mean is we and sometimes I'll say
we and what I mean is they this was a
system that was developed mostly by
students in mind who persuaded me after
a great deal of time that they were
thinking the right kinds of thoughts but
here's how the Genesis architecture
works as there's no surprise given
recent discussions it's all centered on
language and the language part of the
Genesis system has two roles one of
which is to guide and marshal and
interact with the perceptual systems and
the other is to enable the description
of events
Wow
nice going yes yeah that's how it works
so so so it's perception important I
don't know I might ask you a question
like is there anybody sitting in a front
row wearing blue jeans and it's hard for
you to resist under those circumstances
your eyes from going over there and
answering the question your eyes
answered the question no symbol symbol
processing system is involved except
insofar as my language system has
communicated with your language system
which drives your motor system in your
vision system to go over there and
answer the question for you but it's not
just the real stuff that the language
system directs your attention to it's
also the imagined stuff shoot it's been
a long semester if I told you the story
about my table-saw
probably not here's the deal I bought a
table saw it's a wonderful table saw I
was installing it with a friend of mine
who's a cabinet maker he said never wear
gloves when you operate this saw why I
said before he could answer the question
I figured it out can you figure out why
you never wear gloves when the operating
table saw you know what a table saw is
right it says it's a table with a
spinning blade in the middle and use it
to cut wood and why she never wear
gloves yes well you know the answer it's
not fair that's old bread up there he's
heard the story too many times yes how
do you got it
we're talking about somebody who hasn't
been told the answer yes because the
glove might get caught and pull your
hand into the blade and then what
happens you know it's horrible your hand
gets mangled and your fingers get cut
off and this happens a lot to
professionals it won't actually happen
with that table saw that I bought
because it it's played detects flesh and
and stops the blade which then leads to
stopping the blade and having the blade
retreat into the table in about two
microseconds two milliseconds so in
general though it's a bad idea you
always have to praise has to suppose
that the mechanism isn't working anyway
in order to use good safety practice but
here's an example of something that
nobody ever told you that he was able to
figure out by imagining what would
happen and reading the answers off of
the scene that he imagined so nobody
ever says many of the things that we
know but we know them anyway here's
another example imagine running down the
street with a full bucket of water what
happens the water splashes out gets your
leg wet right you won't find that in
open minds database nobody ever said
that over the web it's not written down
anywhere but you know it because you we
human beings have a capacity to imagine
perceptual things and read the answers
to questions off of off of our
imaginations with that perceptual
apparatus so that's a very important
connection down there and then if you
got the ability to describe events then
you've got an ability to tell and
understand stories and if you can do
that then you can start to get a handle
on culture both macro and micro and by
macro culture I mean you're the country
you grew up in the religion you grew up
with and by micro I mean your family and
personal experience and all shades in
between so I don't know what inspires me
and my associates to think in terms in
these terms we talked a little about a
little bit of it last time when I talked
about evolution and the apparent
flowering of our species about 50
thousand years ago which time we got
something and I believe that what we got
and this is the characterization of this
particular hypothesis what we got is the
ability to tell stories and understand
them so if we want to label this
representation that's the label strong
story hypothesis
so what's the week story hypothesis the
week story hypothesis is this is
important the strong story hypothesis is
this all there is but those are any
other evidence that this is really
really really important so the query da
Krishna here before the class starts he
tells me I haven't told you that about
the following experiment this in my way
of thinking is if is the most important
series of experiments ever done in
cognitive psychology developmental
psychology actually so here's the here's
how we get started there's a rectangular
room if you're a person if you're a rat
it's a rectangular box all the walls are
painted white you with me so far
so now in each corner there's a basket
or cloth or something in which under
which in which on under which you can
put some food now you put the food there
while the rat watches you and then you
give the rat a little spin to disorient
it alright so then the rack stops and
goes for the food and you can keep track
of where the rat goes and the rat goes
with approximately equal probability
predominantly to those two corners so it
officially didn't know the rats were
that smart so they understand the
rectangular nature of the room and they
don't go to the diagonal corners where
the food cannot be so these are these
genius rats or maybe we're just rats
with big brains because we do the same
thing so if you repeat this experiment
and replace the rat by us but with it
with a small child and then you
you put a toy in there instead of food
and I ran it and not directed it's the
child is usually held in parents arms
usually the child's mother usually
because they think that if they
participate in these experiments up
there Harvard kid will get into Harvard
someday
so the kid goes to the diagonal corner
just like a rat and then then you next
thing you do is you try it an adult
maybe an MIT student in that case you
can use food again and get the same
result who could be surprised
so rats children and human adult's
pretty much all the same with respect to
this experiment until you paint one wall
blue rats are not colorblind in case
you're wondering then what happens well
if you paint one wall blue the rat still
goes with equal probability to the two
diagonal corners if you think one wall
blue the child still goes to two
diagonal corners of approximately equal
probability it's only as genius human
adult's who go only to that corner so
this invites a couple of questions one
of which is when does a child become an
adult any ideas
lekha what do you think yeah sometimes
you can pick a number greater than one
in less than ten when I saw it even five
pretty good guess to have siblings at
that age it's a surprise but why is it
five is it because what does it relate
to is there any correlate to the onset
of that ability
you might try everything as specky does
because she's extremely careful
so she's tried gender she's tried the
onset of language I don't know the
appreciation of music handedness and
there's only one thing that matters and
that is that the child becomes an adult
at that time when they start to use the
words left' and right' when they
describe the world now I say that very
carefully because they understand left
and right in an earlier age but they
only have started to use the words left'
and right' when they describe the world
at the time that they begin to break
this they need to break this symmetry
and go to the correct corner now for the
next element this I need something to
read say we've got a textbook handy wow
we go ah china illustrated history now I
need to volunteer
okay and you want to do this so here's
what you're going to do you can stay
there but you can need to stand up so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
read to you a passage from this book and
I want you to say it back to me at the
same time I read it it's as if you were
doing in or you know a translation
simultaneous translation except it's
English to English
that's just clean it's got words I can't
pronounce okay you ready to go alright
when overwhelmed by the magnitude of the
problems he tackled he began to suspect
that others were plotting against him or
secretly ridiculing him
so it's not thank you very much
so you see he could do it some people
can't do it at least takes a little
practice but he did it and guess what
I've done to him I reduced his
intelligence to that of a rat
because if you do this experiment with
an adult human with who's doing this
simultaneous English English translation
they go with equal probability to the
two corners so what's happened what's
happened is you Jam their language
processor and when their language
processor is jammed they can't put the
bloob all together with a rectangular
shape so it seems to be that language is
the mediator of exactly the combinators
you need in order to build descriptions
because they can't even put those things
together when the language processor is
jammed by the simultaneous translation
phenomenon so that brings us to two
Goldstar ideas of the day and one is if
you want to make yourself smarter
you want to do those things look listen
draw and talk because those are the
particular mechanisms that surround this
area down in here which is the center of
what we do which is the center of our
thinking so why did you take notes in
class not because you'll ever look at
them before but because it forces the
engagement of your linguistic of your
linguistic your motor and your visual
apparatus and that makes you smarter
because it's exercising that stuff
second thing you can say inclusion
especially from this experiment is aware
of fast talkers why do you want to be
aware of fast talkers it's not because
they will talk you into anything it's
because when they talk fast they're
jamming your language processor and you
can't think that's why you want to be
aware of fast talkers because if they
Jam your language processor you won't
think and you buy that car or you'll buy
that drink or you do any matter of
things that people who have want you to
do those things have learned to do but
wait by talking fast to jam your
processor so that completes what we're
going to do today and give you a
demonstration of some of this stuff on
another occasion
you